في الاثناء قال الجيش التايواني انه يراقب
عن كسب تدريبات التي بدات الصين في مضيق
تايوان صباح اليوم وهي تدريبات تاتي قبيل
لقاء الرئيسه التايوانيات
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي في كاليفورنيا
التدريبات الصينيه توصف بانها عمليه
مشتركه خاصه للرحلات البحريه والدوريه في
مضيق تايوان بقياده سفينه دوريه تعد اول
سفينه صينيه كبيره تقوم بدوريات في مضيق
تايوان كما تم رصد اربع عشره طائره عسكريه
صينيه وثلاثه سفن حربيه في مناطق حول
تايوان منذ الساعه السادسه من مساء امس
الثلاثاء وحتى السادسه من صباح اليوم
الاربعاء
من بيجين بعد مدير مكتب الجزيره ناصر عبد
الحق ناصر اولا هي زياره هامه للرئيس
الفرنسي الى الصين برفقه اورسولا
فوندرلاين
نعم حسن هي زياره مهمه للغايه خاصه
بالنسبه
للاوروبيين وبالنسبه لفرنسا وهناك نقطتين
لابد من توضيحهما هي
العلاقات الفرنسيه الصينيه والعلاقات
الاوروبيه الصينيه وبالتالي جاءت زياره
مكرون هذه ترافقه رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه حيث ان فرنسا بالاضافه الى ما
ذكرتم في الخبر بانها تعلق امال كبيره على
حث الصين على القيام بدور اكثر ايجابيه في
الازمه الاوكرانيه لكن فرنسا ايضا تربطها
مصالح اقتصاديه كثيره مع الصين وتعول
كثيرا على هذه المصالح ولا تريد كما ذكر
الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون بان تتاثر هذه
المصالح وان لا تؤثر الازمه في اوكرانيا
على المصالح الاقتصاديه بين البلدين
وفي المقابل تاتي رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه لتشارك الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون
في هذه الزياره في رساله تحمل خلالها وجهه
النظر الاوروبيه تجاه الازمه الاوكرانيه
ولحث الصين ايضا على بدل مجهود اكبر في
ردع روسيا كما تقول عن الاستمرار في
الهجوم على اوكرانيا وايجاد السياسي لهذه
الازمه لكن الخلاف بين الصين
ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
فيما يتعلق بالازمه الاوكرانيه هي طريقه
حل هذه الازمه فبينما فتقول الصين بينما
تواصل الدول الغربيه والولايات المتحده
بصب الزيت على النار ودعم الجيش الاوكراني
بالاسلحه ترى الصين بانه لابد من حل هذه
الازمه او لا يمكن حل هذه الازمه الا من
خلال الجلوس الى ماده مائده المفاوضات
ومراعاه الهواجس الامنيه لجميع الاطراف
وذلك
يرفض الاوروبيين يرفضه الاوروبيين ربما
ويريدون من روسيا فقط الرجوع الى الحدود
ما قبل الحرب وهذا ما تقول الصين عنه
عندما قالت بانه يجب مراعاه الهواجس
الامنيه لجميع الاطراف وبالتالي
الصين هي ربما لن تكون هذه الزياره لن
تاتي
بالنتائج المرجوه الذي يسعى اليها
الاوروبيين مع الصينيين حيث كما قلت الصين
تصر على موقفها من هذه الازمه وان
علاقاتها مع روسيا هي علاقات استراتيجيه
ولا تستهدف اي طرف اخر نعم حسن
ناصر عبد الحق مدير مكتب الجزيره من بجين
شكرا جزيلا لك